as we get closer and closer to the
november election
i've been talking about how much of
donald trump's behavior
over the next three months is going to
be coming of a place of
desperation from a place of desperation
out of
a sense of desperation and david shipler
wrote a really interesting article
yesterday in washington monthly called
beware of a cornered trump which really
builds on this idea that you and i have
been talking about for a while
that if donald trump's polling continues
to be bad
and remember he's pretending like he
doesn't believe the polling but his
actions speak otherwise
replacing his campaign uh manager um
and all of the you know restarting
coronavirus briefings all wearing a mask
all the things that he's doing
if his polling doesn't improve it
doesn't have to necessarily get worse
but just if it doesn't improve
we would expect based on everything we
know about donald trump
that he would go even more in the
directions
that we have seen him tend to directions
of corruption and depravity
and authoritarian tendencies which will
likely become
even more severe and case in point we're
really already seeing that over the last
couple of weeks the deployment of
camouflage
troops with no badges to portland oregon
where they are throwing people into
unmarked vans and claiming that they're
going to expand to more cities even as
soon as this week and we'll see if that
happens
we're seeing the authoritarianism and
really the desperation and the disregard
for human life manifest
in the demand from trump that schools
just open in the fall health
considerations be damned
just get open we are seeing donald
trump's desperation
to prevent people from voting against
him
manifest in his unhinged opposition to
vote by mail which in practice
this year just means expand absentee
ballots through the process we already
have
to whoever wants it uh just virulent
opposition to that on completely false
and bogus grounds and as david shipler
says in this article which we're going
to link to and i encourage you to read
and i i like this term
trump has no moral breaks there's
nothing there where morality would pump
the brakes for him
david shipler goes on to say his values
are those of a mafia boss
who rewards and punishes those who
protect uh or oppose him
who protect for opposing him uh punishes
those who protect or
oppose him now to be thorough david
shipler also mentions
our fear could be wrong maybe trump
won't go
completely off the rails for example
maybe trump won't send
these armed paramilitaries that are now
being floated in places like portland
maybe trump won't send them to monitor
polling places to intimidate voters in
november
we're worried that he's going to do that
but maybe he won't do it maybe our fear
is overblown and we hope that it's
overblown
in the sense that trump could be too
incompetent or unable to think far
enough ahead
to actually do the horrible things that
he would have no moral problem
doing if trump stops short of what we
fear he would do
it would be not because of a moral
awakening
but because he forgets or is incompetent
or is unable unable to get something
done
but there is this constant feedback loop
or vicious cycle
trump's ignorance and delusions of
grandeur and narcissism
reinforce his most dangerous impulses
which when he does and sees that he gets
a reaction
reinforces his narcissism and delusions
of grandeur and
victimhood mentality that no one's been
treated as poorly as him
you combine this with this silver spoon
upbringing and what appears to be
probably some personality disorders
based
on the mental health professionals we've
spoken to there is no
check on trump's behavior anywhere and
in fact when we hear that trump
had an idea and didn't carry it out it
typically is because either a he gets
distracted by
something else or b a group of people in
his
in his administration are able to talk
him out of it or prevent him from doing
it and then he moves on to something
else
it comes down to what can he get away
with
what can the people around him stop him
from doing
and it also shouldn't be ignored that
the administration
is in itself a threat by virtue of its
mere existence this is an administration
that has been a threat to the economy
it's been a threat to international
relations and our alliances with other
countries
the administration obviously in what
we're seeing with coronavirus
has been an existential threat to public
health there continues to be a
shockingly large percentage
of americans though that still support
the president
and still support this administration
despite everything that's going on right
now
and that is sort of part two of how a
desperate trump becomes a dangerous
trump
some portion of trump supporters and
i don't know what the number is but i
fear that it's a larger percentage than
we want to admit
some portion of trump supporters are
willing to do violence like real world
violence
if that's what donald trump suggests or
implies
or in any way signals may be appropriate
and so when donald trump said to chris
wallace on sunday
when asked can you just say you'll
accept the election results trump didn't
do it he said
i have to see the election results
before i can tell you whether i would
accept them
when you start to hear about the
paramilitaries showing up in portland
we have to remember that a portion of
this man's followers
are more than willing some are eager to
get out there and commit physical
violence
on the streets in the name of donald
trump trump has
shown us that if we try to predict
how far he will go we're always wrong
he's always willing to go further than
whatever our predictions are
at any point in time and the more
cornered he gets and that's what i
believe he increasingly is right now
the more outrageous and belligerent his
behavior
is going to get i wonder what stories
there are to be told which maybe we will
hear someday
about the things trump almost did during
this administration
and someone was just barely able to but
was able to
stop him from doing it you know the
stories about the things he did are bad
enough
there must be just a treasure trove of
nightmares
about the things he almost did that
someone stopped him from doing and the
next three
plus months three three months and a few
weeks up until the election
are likely to be the most dangerous
trump
because of the desperation and the
feeling cornered
and the cognitive stuff is increasingly
taking
center stage and i want to talk about
that a little bit next
let me tell you real quick about one of
our sponsors cuts
clothing they offer super quality men's
t-shirts and they're giving you
15 off when you go to davidpakman.com
cuts that's c-u-t-s because
solid color t-shirts are a really
important staple
in pretty much every guy's wardrobe i
think it's really important not to
overlook the value of having t-shirts
you love wearing
t-shirts from cuts clothing have been a
game changer for me and as a company all
they deal with
are men's solid color t-shirts so they
actually put a ton of thought
into the comfort the style the
durability of the t-shirts they make
they fit perfectly they're not scratchy
they don't shrink they don't fade they
don't stretch out over time like so many
other t-shirts they're really the most
comfortable t-shirts i've owned
and they look great this right here that
i'm wearing
on youtube is the split hem
crew neck t-shirt very soft
fits me perfectly it's the ideal length
go take a look at what they offer and
once you have it
you are really going to see and feel the
difference
their slogan is it's the only shirt
worth wearing
you will see why and you'll get 15 off
when you do it
by going to davidpakman.com cuts
that's davidpakman.com c-u-t-s